so we heard from tom brady with michelle
tafoya's
post-game interview on the field bill
belichick has been at the podium in the
last couple of minutes let's listen into
his comments after this two-point
patriots loss tonight
all right well it's obviously a little
disappointed to come up short here
tonight um
thought that
you know we had our chances and
just could have done a couple things a
little bit better
um i mean it will change the outcome but
we just uh
you know
just just felt a little bit short so
i thought our team really prepared well
this week and that's what we got to do
every week and
coach a little bit better and
make a few more plays and
and start winning these close games
first question nick o'malley
hey bill uh you coached uh tom brady
practice for 20 years but this is the
first time you went ahead against him in
a game what was the experience like
going look we went against tom brady
every day every day in practice
defensively so it's not like we've never
seen tom brady before
was the experience of coaching gets him
in the game any different
they're a good football team he's great
quarterback i mean i think that's all
goes without saying
and if you have questions we'll pass
mike to you
joe chaota
bill just your thoughts on mac jones
today showing a lot of poise uh has a
rookie back there what are your thoughts
on his performance today
well go look at the film you know i
thought again i thought our team played
competitively and you know matt's
certainly part of that um you know we
can all you know play better and i'll
learn from you know some of the things
we could have done better but
you know mac fought hard and made a lot
of plays for us
hey coach uh how do you plan to address
your fun to fumble these shoes looks
like you have a lot uh this season and
today was a critical situation too
yeah that's more important than ball
security
steve sanchez
uh bill defensively held them two you
know three field uh three field goals
and a touchdown or four field goals yeah
four field goals in a touchdown so
it was a good performance
yeah well
not not enough
brendan mcguire
bill anything stand out about the
running game tonight from you guys was
it just
you know tampa bay executing we couldn't
do a good we couldn't get much going
there
they're they're obviously a good run
defense but
we couldn't
we couldn't get much done there and uh
yeah that was disappointing you know we
have
we have good back so we haven't been
able to really get them started very
often so it's definitely something we
need to work on and do better
bill specifically about mac just
being able to lead comebacks within the
game
is that a learned skill is that
something he could take coming out of
this game and i did also want to ask you
if you wouldn't mind explaining what you
were told about the matt slater play and
if you've ever seen matt that upset with
a call
yeah it's a tough call you have to talk
to the guys that made it
um there's a couple tough calls there
but you know we talked to them about
that
yeah i mean look matt's max a good good
player and
you know he knows how to compete knows
how to win
you know he can learn things tonight
like we all can
so we will
andrew callahan to the left
uh bill what about matching jc
jalen and jonathan jones kind of each
shadowing a bucks receiver for most of
tonight
what made you feel that was the best
decision and how do you think that
played out through the course of the
game
why did we think it was the best
decision we thought was the best
decision
oh no how do you want to do it
any questions guys
[Music]
hey bill yeah i may have missed it i
just got got in here earlier but um what
did you see you've seen tom brady play
so many games over so long
this game with
all the emotions and obviously
the chess match against you what
what what did you see from tom tonight
that
that may have kept it as competitive as
it was
yeah i think we already covered that
that's one of the first questions yep
was there any consideration of going for
it on the left fourth down when you
kicked the field at the end
i mean not really
bill um what were some of the things you
guys did to maybe
try to keep the bucks guessing
offensively in terms of the the number
of rushers
that you decided to bring at different
points
what what are we trying i don't
understand the question
how did you try to confuse the bucks
with your
yeah we used multiple
multiple rushes and mobile coverages
been doing that all year
i don't think it was anything
i don't think it was not a big surprise
to them but you'd have to ask them i
don't know
okay thank you
[Laughter]
thank you that's exactly what it is it's
classic it is classic the the people
asking the questions
it's like they've been hit by a blitz
before
it's chuck and duck it's exactly what it
is from the reporters uh in any case
let's move to mack jones
and in in a few more words than coach
belichick
drew can you describe how mac jones
played here tonight as he uh threw it 40
times completely 31 passes well first
off in in those conditions it it was
unbelievable and and going up against
that defense and the fact that he had
zero run game the entire game they just
put it on his shoulders watch his eyes
down the field feels the free rusher
just a quick slide and still in a great
position to put his foot down and
deliver that ball accurately here watch
how he works his way through the
progression all these crossing routes
finds the open receiver to get him into
the end zone and here again
feeling the free rusher he knows where
they're coming from he's able to escape
just enough to buy some time to get a
positive play as opposing to getting a
sack negative play
i can't tell you how impressive with his
poise with his composure with his
command in this offense tony as we look
at the numbers comparing two he throws
the two touchdowns brady no touchdowns
no picks in his return to foxborough are
your thoughts on mack jones i thought he
was outstanding tonight it was obvious
todd bowles the bucks defensive
coordinator once carlton davis got hurt
he felt like his only shot was to blitz
and he brought every kind of pressure
you could imagine and we saw those free
rushers coming usually the quarterback's
gonna just get rid of it throw it hot
mac jones just take my time i know where
everybody is i thought he played with
just outstanding poise for a young guy
under these conditions
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports